came up with what I call a two percent
difference so what most people do is
focus on how do I plan to 100 I'm going
to start a podcast so I need to have
look at howlin's setup he's got the TVs
and he's got the microphone and he's got
the right and people would look at that
I need all that before I start the two
percent difference is if you trust a
great ideas flow through you then what's
the first two percent what's the first
two percent that you can do right now
just to get started and don't expect it
to be perfect expect it to suck but
momentum for most people is the only
thing that's missing we often use our
best energy on planning and so you come
up with an idea and then you plan and
you planning you plan and plan you
strategies and then a week goes by I
know you realize you don't have the same
courage and boldness that you had a week
ago